just two episodes after Game of Thrones
gave Arya Stark a stunning romance scene
the series completely dropped the ball
with another female character at least
in the eyes of countless fans around the
world beware spoilers are coming the 4th
episode of Game of Thrones final season
the last of the Starks picked up right
after the brutal Battle of Winterfell
before Arya Stark vanquished the night
king and his frosty minions many good
people sacrificed their lives to protect
Winterfell and the rest of Westeros
Daenerys Targaryen and Jon Snow
attempted to flame out the enemy with
their dragons and Brienne of Tarth put
her new status as a knight of the Seven
Kingdoms to use fighting the White
Walkers as the commander of her own
section of soldiers one of those
soldiers was the man who knighted her
Jaime Lannister Brienne and Jaime have
had a complex history throughout the run
of Game of Thrones the pair first met in
season two when he was a prisoner they
eventually grew closer throughout the
course of the series but they've
certainly had more than a few clashes
Jamie even gave Brienne his Valyrian
steel sward Oathkeeper for her mission
to keep the stark girl safe clearly
there's a lot of love between Jaime and
Brienne but nothing ever came of their
feelings
perhaps because Jaime has been blindly
in love with his sister
Cersei that all changed on season 8
episode 4 when Jaime and Brienne shared
an intimate night together after a
drinking game took a turn for the
personal the romantic moment was
everything you could have hoped for but
then the show took that shiny moment and
tarnished it in a flash in the eyes of
many viewers the romantic scene was
ruined just a few minutes after it all
went down when word got out that euron
greyjoy had ambushed
Daenerys his fleet and slaughtered her
dragon ragel worse still news reached
Winterfell that Circe's minions had
captured Daenerys as handmaiden miss on
day shortly after Brienne delivered the
terrible news to Jaime he slipped away
into the night to head for King's
Landing what he plans to do there is a
mystery but Jamie's departure left
Brienne utterly brokenhearted
you're good none and you can't save her
you don't need to die with her stay here
stay with me as Brienne subs Jaime runs
through all the horrific things he's
done over the years for Cersei like
pushing bran stark out of a window and
paralyzing him for life attempting to
show Brienne who he truly is he says
she's hateful and so am I
and with that Jamie rides off to King's
Landing and Brienne's soft sobs echo
through the night chance immediately
took to Twitter to express their
distress Brienne crying is something I
never want to see again another Twitter
user was evidently having a breakdown
what should have been our Jaime and
Brienne moment got completely ruined and
I'm so angry I want to cry another fan
took aim at the Game of Thrones writers
tweeting good morning I only came online
to say that Brienne deserves better and
the writers completely ruined years of
Jaime's development
one viewer defended the scene writing
Brienne is crying because she more than
anyone has seen his character growth and
now he's turning back on that growth
he's giving up
clearly the Jaime and Brienne romance
has ruffled a lot of feathers but
there's a potential bright side
Jaime might be going to King's Landing
to kill Cersei perhaps he's planning to
return to Winterfell to live out the
rest of his days with Brienne could the
Kingslayer possibly become the queen
Slayer and then become Brienne's new bow
on the next episode of Game of Thrones
will simply have to wait and see check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]